much of the academic Decay at American
University stems you know from its
cult-like adherence to the binary system
of oppress versus oppressor and it is
the very Foundation of Communism and it
is what your kids are being
indoctrinated into at many American
universities joining us now with
analysis is the author of the upcoming
book uh we've got issues how you can
stand strong for our country soul and
Sanity the host of the brand new uh show
Dr Phil Prime Time the one and only our
good friend Dr Phil you know what always
defines I look at you what has always
Define you to me is your willingness to
just say it as it is and not worry about
consequences here you're talking about
genocide of Jews uh and then of course
we want to back off but we we apply one
standard to different identity groups
but not to the Jewish people why at
Harvard and these Southern schools you
know Sean it's it's really disgusting
and it's so hypocritical to hear Harvard
talking about well it's free speech they
wouldn't know Free Speech if it came up
and bit them in the ass because this is
something that as you pointed out fire
puts them 248 out of 248 they had to set
up an entire new category for them they
were so abysmal at it and it's not they
don't do Free Speech they do their
speech and as I I've had people on my
show Dr Carol Huen who you alluded to a
few minutes ago that just went out and
reported the science just reported the
science and she was labeled uh as hate
speech and drummed out of the University
after 20 plus years uh but yet you can
talk about uh genocide of Jews and you
know genocide is an interesting term it
doesn't sound real bad if you say it
real fast but the definition of it is to
kill a large number of an ethnic group
with the purpose of white wiping them
off the face of the Earth and destroying
their nation and that's what we're
talking about here but there are even
exceptions to free speech I'm not a
lawyer I don't mean to brag but I'm not
but there are exceptions to free speech
you cannot incite people to violence
which they're doing you cannot Target
someone uh with specific threats which
they're doing but still we're not
talking about speech here we're talking
about actions they're they're blocking
impeding people's path to their classes
they're they're going in and disrupting
their classes going into the library and
intimidating these students and they're
saying oh well that just doesn't violate
our policies that's insane Sean you know
it and I know it and so does anybody
with common sense this is a double
standard and it's and you know Carolyn
gay is just an she's a symptom of the
problem as well as a perpetrator of the
problem this Cuts really deep into these
ivy league universities you know was an
interesting editorial in the New York
Post yesterday one down and hundreds to
go that it's not just MIT and upen and
Harvard uh this is now institutionalized
but it's institutionalized in lower
grades as well Dr Phil I don't know uh
why all of a sudden we've gotten to a
point where where Educators for kids
from in grammar school even in high
school that they feel that their values
are superior to parental values and they
feel at Liberty to indoctrinate these
children into their way of thinking uh
rather than sticking to the basics
Reading Writing Math Science History and
computers I don't know call me
oldfashioned Dr Phil but I prefer they
educate our kids not indoctrinate
them well Sean over 30% of our fifth
graders and eighth graders cannot read
at the most basic level 19% of our high
school graduates can't read They're
getting passed so the schools can get
paid and yet they're wanting to talk
about other things and that is
completely absurd and what's happening
here and it's happening from the primary
grades up through college is your right
they're running their own woke agendas
and that is absolutely unacceptable and
these people that are counseling these
students on these issues whether they're
psychological or medical don't have
training in Psychology they don't have
training in medicine they don't have tra
training in sociology so they're not
trained in any of the discip that would
qualify them to counsel these students
on these issues and they're excluding
the parents they've known these kids
sometimes for two or three weeks and
they exclude the parents completely and
they don't have the training to do this
they need to stick to what they're
trained to do and most of the and most
of the teachers Sean would prefer to do
that this is getting jammed down their
throats just like it is everybody else
the teachers are not the problem it's
the policy makers and the teacher unions
that are creating the problems all right
quick last question uh I'm glad you're
coming back on TV where can people find
your new
show well it's Merit Street Media and
we're going to be launching at the end
of February and uh I'm going to be
asking you to be part of this uh you and
I have been friends for a long time and
we've got an awful lot of common common
thoughts and uh I'm I'm sure we'll be
crossing paths as we go along here Sean
and I appreciate you let speak on this
today you got to aim higher if I'm on
the list in the beginning you got to go
a little bit higher I'm sure you can get
better people but we're glad to have you
back uh it's been a while we appreciate
you Dr Phil you're a good man sir God
bless you uh all right appreciate it
coming up is Biden turning his back on
Israel you're not going to believe what
he told prime minister Netanyahu plus
the FBI warning of a heightened threat
to Public Safety this holiday season H I
wonder if Joe's 8 million unvetted
illegal immigrants might possibly be
part of that cause Straight
Ahead hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else